you need to wipe down
what's with the jeans while I was gone
by the way sac town ball Sacramento was
a fantastic we have a lot to cover there
we're going to get into some of the
outside details but the shows were a lot
of fun amazing crowds you just have the
best fans up there
where's me the best fans everywhere
seaman Brian they all came out in Bray
are you so much fun thank you mommies
for coming I knew you were in there I
could hear ya you tell it their mommies
cuz they laugh at certain things that
yeah people don't it's great well it's
also um it was really neat I walked on
stage one of my shows and a girl was
sitting in the front row and with a
marker she had written on her forehead
hey Heather so you look at a girl marker
and I'm like oh or lipstick I don't know
it's just right I go hey Hitler's on
your forehead alarians
like yeah and all these people were like
hey look screaming hey guys
the club the employees are like what is
going yeah it's a girl and the other
calm or the other audience members were
like why is that going
ah the hey Hitler theme has been one of
my favorite because it's probably the
most inappropriate thing we've ever got
for the mosan yeah but it's the most fun
and look if you're on board you're on
board if you're not go fuck yourself
you're not a mommy